all right draft today we got another
draft inspired by the
soccer super league because if you
haven't heard it's already dead it's
gone it's over kaput finito
so today's draft short-lived nfl stories
this one was not easy to research
christopher you got the trivia question
for me fire away no no it was not i
think uh got some good creative ones
though that i came up with so but yeah
it was not the easiest one you couldn't
do this one off the top of your head all
right
um man this is an easy question all
right what stat did brady best mahomes
in last season passing yards
passing tds or qb rating
that would be qb rating
i think that's a
wow
he had more passing wow he was the only
brady and rogers were the only ones to
get a bu uh to 40 or above i believe
right oh and russell wilson got to 42.
okay it wasn't that easy all right you
got the first pick you got your first
pick go okay um i think when i think of
short-lived stories that i was excited
for
uh that fizzled out but still fizzled
out in kind of a fun way just like you
know this super league or whatever how
about antonio brown to the raiders okay
talk about a short-lived story with a
lot of action in a short time oh gosh
you know whoa it's going to be awesome
what's antonio brown and john gruden
going to be like when's it going to blow
up when are they going to get in the
first fight you know in the on the
sideline because antonio didn't get 100
catches in one game and all that i was
so excited to see that whole play out
how's john gruden gonna use him oh wait
the guy doesn't like his helmet oh he
doesn't want to come to practice because
he doesn't like the helmet change all of
that then he burns his freezes his feet
and does all those damn things so to me
that's one of the best short-lived
stories i can think of here in recent
history
yeah he never actually played in a
regular season game for the oakland
raiders he was cut labor day weekend at
his demand at his insistence and off he
went all right i actually i think it was
the weekend of the first game it was the
weekend of the first game he's had a
monday night or that year he was cut on
saturday they were getting ready to play
on monday night uh this i'm surprised
you didn't take this one
the the very very short stint of bill
belichick as hc the good guy yj
written on a cocktail napkin i resigned
as hc of the nyj he was the head coach
for like a day
had that clunky clumsy press conference
becomes the head coach of the new
england patriots and the rest is history
so from short-lived to one of the
greatest tenures we've ever seen from a
head coach
all in very close proximity chris yeah
no that that's a it was a pretty amazing
48 hours or so there i mean it really
was and you know even the stories you
know behind it as far as
belichick and parcells that caused a
little issue with their relationship for
a few years everything like that
uh pretty amazing it really is
uh okay my next one
i think i'm gonna have to go with um
elway to the colts all right that that's
like one of the the short-lived ones
that'll always jump out to me there of
course they pick up number one
he's told everybody he doesn't want to
really play there do that you're going
wait what's gonna happen this guy's
great career you know he goes and says
hey the hell with it i'm gonna go play
third base and the yankees does all that
kind of crap and eventually you know it
gets it gets sorted out to where they
trade him to denver but i guess why it's
such a great short-lived story too is
you know
at that that was uns
that was i don't know to my knowledge
nobody did that he was the first one to
really do that right to kind of go like
i'm not playing for a team i remember
seeing the old clips of like terry
bradshaw at the time going like who the
hell does john elway think he is doing
this
so i thought that was a pretty good
short-lived story for me
um i i agree that was a good one uh next
one for me and i got two more that i
really like i'm gonna pick this one
because i don't think you're gonna get
the third one i don't think you're even
aware of the third one the second one is
bill parcells as head coach of the tampa
bay buccaneers because that's where he
was going that's what he was doing right
mike tannenbaum actually took the job as
the gm of the tampa bay buccaneers he
was ready to go and then it's time to
walk to the order and parcell says nah
i'm good see you later tampa bay
buccaneers so i still remember that one
vividly and that that that was the first
domino
that ultimately resulted in john gruden
getting that job in 2002. yeah yeah
that's right i really i had totally
forgot about that little chain of events
there and that have been interesting do
you think parcells could have been your
first head coach it's been amazing
wouldn't that have been perfect that
would have been crazy that have been
crazy i you know my dad uh always said
he thought his first name began with an
f with bill parcells i probably would
have had the same one so
that's pretty good all right i'm going
um i'm going a fun one here short-lived
nfl stories um how about the vikings
chances of making the super bowl in the
2000 nfc championship game
that was a short-lived story you want to
talk about hey vikings gonna go back to
the super bowl that's awesome offense
we're gonna do it
mike florio's gonna be real happy boom
that game was over in the end of the
first quarter ceo vikings
short-lived story that lasted three
minutes of hope for the floriel family
yes sorry i just didn't give that the
only the only blowout in a conference
championship game ever how'd that super
bowl turn out for the giants that year
by the way it was a little bit of a
blowout a little bit of a blowout sorry
yep it was a blowout
so that would have been a short-lived
story as well from the same cycle the
same season technically i think the
giants are in there longer than your
vikings did so at least give them that
that was the first super bowl
that i actually worked i didn't go to it
but i was in the business then yeah and
i said
based upon my careful analysis of the
team whoever scores the first touchdown
wins the game for a change one of the
only times in my life i was right first
team that scored a touchdown won that
game uh just because there weren't going
to be many touchdown score but the
ravens ended up scoring uh
right last one for me and and
and you may not be aware that this even
happened but for a very short period of
time in early 1996 when the la market
was vacant the seahawks were going to
move there
they told their employees we're heading
to l.a they were going to play at the
rose bowl the rose bowl officials said
we don't know what the hell they're
talking about the seahawks said pack it
up off we go and the league got involved
and basically said oh you guys aren't
going anywhere but there was a short
period of time and that's the one that
to me
seems the most like this super league
thing like here we go we're doing this
and it was dead in 48 hours and the
seahawks
stayed in seattle paul allen bought the
team and they're there for good i like
vaguely remember that you know a little
bit but i didn't realize it had gotten
that serious to where like seattle was
really like going no we're going pack
you know pack the building up i don't i
don't know if i remembered that so that
that's a good one i i like that a lot
that'd have been interesting the los
angeles seahawks there is a seat they
told the coaches they told the coaches
they were moving to pasadena and
employees were advised to pack their
personal effects because the team was
going to lock its offices by noon
because they were moving to anaheim and
they were going to take over rams park
as their headquarters because the rams
had moved to san luis obispo right wow
that's the whole story what was that
other one you were talking about didn't
you have one more that you said you you
wanted to get to or no is that it no i
no no that was the parcells i think i
had a couple others that were just
filler if we ran out of if you took any
of my ideas but they weren't great i was
going to say julian edelman is all a
famer that was a short-lived story yeah
yeah um foxborough forever isn't it
funny how quickly that went away yeah
well i think when people like hear facts
they start to go oh wait yeah you're
right i was stupid to think of that yeah
everybody got it out of their system
very quickly and now it's gone and it
will never be brought up again pete
mentioned goodwin frank gore to the
eagles one of the few players exercising
his prerogative to agree to terms
during the negotiating window but
ultimately not signed the contract frank
gore did that anthony barr member of the
jets that happened and then it didn't so
it doesn't happen very often but it
definitely does i did have randy moss
part two to the vikings that was one
more that i was gonna take a shot to you
with that was gonna happen yeah that
would have been that would have been
more of a biting shot because let me
tell you something
i was telling paul allen voice the
vikings and host on kfan in minneapolis
i've been going on a show every week for
15 years i kept saying to him 2007 2008
2009 randy moss is coming back at some
point mark my words he's coming back at
some point so i was very vindicated and
proud that i was right and then three
weeks later
programmatic non-fit is what brad
childress had to say second brad
childress reference of the day and the
last
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports